منوراتهم ضخمه مشاهدينا تحاكي حربا شامله
بداها الجيش الفرنسي في اربع عشره مقاطعه
في جنوب البلاد وتستمر حتى الحادي عشر من
مارس المقبل
المناوره ما هي هي تحمل اسم اوريون يشارك
فيها سبعه الاف جندي كان مخططا لها منذ
عام 20 20 واكتسبت اهميه اضافيه منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا هذه المناوره مشاهدينا
تعد الاكبر منذ نهايه الحرب البارده تحاكي
احداثها فكره مواجهه عدو وهمي اسمه
ميركوري هو دوله قويه نشرت ميليشيات
انفصاليه في اقليم ارنيلاند الوهمي ايضا
وهو الحليف لباريس الجزء الاول من هذه
المناوره كيف سيكون سيكون على شكل انزال
قوات برا وبحرا وجوا بل بحرا وجوا بمشاركه
حامله الطائرات
وحملت حملتي طائرات هليكوبتر
مائيتين كما نتابع في هذه الصوره اما
الجزء الثاني سيكون محاكاه لغز مباشر كما
نتابع تحاول هذه القوات الفرنسيه صده عبر
مشاركه 10 او 12 الف رجل على جبهه بطول 50
كيلومتر وعمق 200 كيلومتر مع تعبئه جميع
موارد الجيش ماذا سيجري خلال هذه العمليه
سيتم اجراء عمليه انزال برمائي كما نتابع
هنا ل 700 جندي و150 مركبه على ساحل البحر
المتوسط ومشاهدينا يعود تاريخ اخر عمليه
بهذا الحجم في ظروف حقيقيه الى عمليه
سيرفال في مالي عام
2012 عندما استولى الجنود الفرنسيون عندما
استولوا على مدينه تومباكتو